Johnny Depp and Amber Heard listen their
defamation trial dominated headlines so
you knew it was only a matter of time
until someone turned it into a movie our
daddy director is with the Stars
bringing the case back to life all right
court is now in session six weeks of
this trial was live streamed across the
globe why do you think this trial was
such a Temptation people are fascinated
by watching human beings go through hard
things two people can watch it and have
completely different perspectives of it
Mark hapka is Johnny Depp Megan Davis
Amber Heard the resemblance is kinda
amazing since we've shot people are like
does anyone ever tell you you look like
a young Johnny Depp I'm like this is
really timely the hair is longer it used
to be short I never had facial hair so I
think a lot of that really makes or
breaks certain roles The Ripped from the
headlines movie hits all the infamous
highlights rumored Affairs another one
with James Franco
drugs and dramatic testimony I hope I
get my voice back it's all that I want
this is uh not been easy for any of us
and there's a Twist can't wait to see
what's next hot take the depth herd
trial which premieres tomorrow on 2B
takes you inside the Imagine thoughts of
Johnny and Amber he was very very sick
for at least two days I decided I needed
to do something to help him I might have
been going a little too hard I think
what I what I was most surprised by was
how much love I found between the two of
them shut up
get over here I think it's cute yeah I
felt like if there's an opportunity here
that I could maybe bring some
understanding and love and compassion to
this person that's that's all I think
any artist wants to do
foreign